rights groups and the international
community are raising alarm over the
human rights situation in uganda raising
attention to what they call recurring
credible accounts of arbitrary arrests
false disappearances and torture in the
east african country
they're blaming the government of
president yueri museveni who's been in
power since
1986.
now there's outrage after writer
kakuenza rukira bishaija alleged he was
tortured for weeks while in detention
after being arrested in december a
magistrate ordered his release last
month he has since published images of
his back on social media showing clear
signs of alleged torture
while kakura kira bashaija has now fled
uganda human rights watch is demanding
that uganda should drop all charges
against him and investigate his
allegations the satirist's most recent
book is banana republic where writing is
treasonous and then he's also the author
of the 2020 historical novel which is
the greedy barbarian which describes a
high level corruption in a fictional
country
now before rikira bashar
i spoke to him in kampala and i first
asked him to describe
what happened to him when he was
detained last year
now on
28 december i was home and military men
broke into it and
violently arrested me without any arrest
warrant and
took me to a
special forces command
the the military the army that is
responsible for the president's
um
security and his immediate relatives and
i was detained there for
14 days
and during the detention
they tortured me to almost death and
inflicted grievous
damage to my skin my body
and
i was later smuggled into court and
sent to prison
which is actually
a miscarriage of justice as our laws
elusive debt because
when a person is ordered as per our our
human rights act
when the magistrate or the judge
presiding over the matter realizes that
the
suspect is tortured
he cannot send him to the hospital i
mean to the prison instead he sends him
to the
hospital but
the magistrate decided to send me to
prison
and
even when i was bailed
when i was bailed they they came and
re-arrested me from the prison and
took me again to the military detention
do you have any suspicions about who may
have ordered these acts
of course it is the president's son
the one who ordered for my arrest he's
done who presided over my torture
yes
and i've met him three times during the
interrogation
yes so he's the one who was in charge of
my torture
when you mentioned the alleged torture
can you give us a little bit more detail
about what happened to you
i received punches in the stomach when
they were arresting me
they beat me they hit my ankles using
buttons bludgeons when they
took me to the interrogation center in
the detention center
they used hippopotamus whips or wires to
inflict
dermatological restorations all over my
body that is
the medical report says
they hit my back
all my body is full of
scars
yeah so
they really hit me bad to the extent
that i
i collapsed and
gained consciousness after like six
hours
was the president's son president during
this torture
yes he was
you physically saw him there in the same
room
yes i saw him i met him he asked me to
give me an offer and
of a job in in form of a job and some
other material benefits i refused
he begged me not to write about my touch
again because he knows that
uh even after this arrest i am going to
write another book so he begged me even
when
i was taken when i was kidnapped from
prison it was kind of caution he met me
again and
told me not to write and he said let me
first heal i will think about it
so you've been warned not to speak to
the press yet you've decided to give
interviews to the media anyway
before your trial concludes in march are
you worried that speaking out could lead
to you being arrested again do you fear
for your life
they know where they know i stay if they
want to arrest me they will come back
and arrest me i don't care
and have you been able to receive
treatment after you were brutally beaten
we saw some pictures that you had
published on social media
with the bruises on your back
i have not received any medical
attention i went to the hospital they
did a diagnosis they did
everything and i was referred to germany
but
my quote was my passport was deposited
in two quarters one of the conditions
for bail
[Music]
yesterday but one we put in an
application to get my passport back so
that i can travel to germany
and the magistrate who is
a miscellaneous refuse to give me back
my passport so i think he wants to try a
corpse he wants me dead
and
yeah that is that is what they want they
want me dead they don't want me to go
and get medical treatment
they are sending me to the desktops here
in uganda for which they cannot even
manage my condition
so i that is why i am determined to
speak against my torture if they want to
arrest me again if they arrest me again
and they get ashamed
this isn't the first time you were
arrested and detained this also happened
back in 2020 where you described the
situation as in you inhumane and
degrading
where does this leave the the future of
satire and freedom of expression in
uganda
i believe that
the president who is in state house
actually
illegitimate that he will not live
forever
so even if
he actually touched the wrong button you
cannot there is no leader in world
history who has ever won a battle
against reuters
that is on record so i actually repeat
to him if he thinks that he will outlive
at satire
he will not live forever he will not
live to keep frustrating at you know
writing he will never going forward now
what do you think needs to be done to
ensure that there is more accountability
of course the president has to go seven
must go
the sole problem we have as a country
him and his son now the son wants he
thinks that the presidency is a kind of
a heritage he wants to inherit his
father's barbarism
so we have to send them off all of them
kakwenza rukira bashaija ugandan writer
thank you very much for your testimony
and speaking to dw news africa
thank you so much for hosting me
so rakira bashaija alleges torture and
attempted bribery by general kaine
rugaba the satirist had in the past
referred to the ugandan president's son
as pig-headed and plump for his part the
general denies any claims of torture and
says he has never met the writer on
twitter he wrote i don't know who this
young boy is whom they say was beaten i
never heard of him i've never met him or
talked to him
now dw news africa also reached out to
the ugandan authorities about these
allegations of arrest and torture here's
part of the response from the government
spokesperson of wanda oppondo
for now the government has no evidence
and the government cannot
operate
on hearsay
because suspects can allege anything
yes
we have seen that before
somebody could have had pre-existing
condition
what we can say is that
torture
is illegal
according to uganda constitution
according to the human rights commission
act
according to the anti-torture law
ugandans should have a right
first of all
to criticize government
and to criticize
government officials including the
president
the government sees no problem
whatsoever
because we are in a democracy
we are in a democracy with free speech
free intellectual discourse
and giving
divergence points of view as long as you
don't impose it is up to the individuals
to choose
to use the language of decorum
or insulting
how about a policeman how about a
soldier
who perhaps is a semi-educated he
doesn't know the law
he may be
carried away
by emotion
by anger he has pursued
a criminal a suspected criminal and he
thinks this person has wasted their time
it is understandable if this kind of
policeman
arrest this person
and goes
overboard even when it is not official
policy it is understandable in me i
would appreciate the anger of that
policeman the anger of that secret
officer
you